salut les épicurieuses et les epicurieux
peut-on vraiment se fier à ce que l'on
voit de nos propres yeux
pas sûr
regardez ces deux traits rouges on est
d'accord celui-ci est plus petit que
celui-là et bien non il suffit de
masquer une partie de l'image et vous
constater qu'ils font exactement la même
taille c'est ce qu'on appelle une
illusion d'optique allez aujourd'hui
spécialement pour vous j'en ai
sélectionné 5 parmi les pubs fortes
[Musique]
vous souvenez certainement de cette robe
en 2015 elle a rendu fou des millions
d'internautes personne n'arrivait à
s'accorder sur sa couleur ah tu veux
dire la fameuse robe bleue avec des
rayures noires
tu veux parler de celle-ci sauf que moi
je la vois
comme ça blanche avec des rayures jaunes
alors selon vous lequel de nous deux
perçoit les bonnes couleurs c'est moi
toi tu es complètement Miro
à moins que l'on ait tous les deux
raisons tentons d'y voir plus clair bleu
et noir blanche et doré la réponse ne se
trouve pas sur la robe mais dans notre
cerveau car c'est lui qui fabrique les
couleurs au niveau de l'air visuel situé
à l'arrière du cerveau à cet endroit il
agit comme un véritable logiciel de
retouche photo il devient capable de
corriger lui-même l'exposition c'est à
dire l'intensité de lumière reçue à ceci
prête que chaque individu effectue cette
correction à sa manière résultat
certains voient la robe bleue et noir
d'autres blanches avec des rayures
dorées si vous n'avez pas peur des
fantômes vous allez adorer cette
illusion
il me rappelle quelqu'un celui-là
commencez par fixer pendant 20 secondes
le point bleu au centre de cette image
très important ne détournez pas le
regard et ne clignez surtout pas des
yeux
[Musique]
allez vous y êtes presque
attention je vais maintenant laisser
place à un fond blanc et voilà mon
fantôme se magnifique je le savais bien
que c'était lui vous pouvez même cligner
régulièrement des yeux pour faire
perdurer l'image alors je vous rassure
il n'y a rien de surnaturel là-dedans
cette illusion illustre le phénomène
d'images rémanente la représentation
persiste après la disparition de l'objet
qui a produit l'image ce phénomène bien
connu porte un nom la persistance
rétinienne l'image se forme sur la
rétine et ne disparaît pas immédiatement
l'illusion fonctionne grâce à la
surstimulation des cellules qui
composent les photos récepteurs de nos
yeux et que l'on détourne le regard le
cerveau interprète les signaux reçus et
compensent en inversant les couleurs le
négatif devient alors positif et mon
fantôme apparaît attention les yeux
toujours voici maintenant l'illusion de
la danseuse en rotation regardez
attentivement cette pour moi elle tourne
dans le sens des aiguilles d'une montre
change de lunettes elle tourne dans le
sens inverse c'est étonnant non nous ne
voyons pas du tout la même chose pour
les uns à la danseuse effectue une
rotation de la droite vers la gauche et
pour les autres de la gauche vers la
droite maintenant
concentrez-vous bien et imaginez qu'elle
change de sens comme par miracle
certains l'aviront inversé sa rotation
alors je sais il faut parfois un petit
peu de temps mais ça peut fonctionner ça
y est vous l'avez c'est dingue vous
n'êtes pas fou c'est votre cerveau qui
vous joue des tours arrêtons-nous un
instant à ce moment précis de la
rotation vous remarquerez que la
silhouette noire au milieu ne laisse
aucun indice pour savoir si la danseuse
se trouve de face comme sur l'image de
droite ou de dos comme sur l'image de
gauche
inconsciemment votre cerveau choisit
l'une ou l'autre position et en fonction
de son choix la danseuse tournera donc
dans un sens ou dans l'autre mais cela
n'explique pas pourquoi certains
réussissent à la voir changer de sens
alors regardez de plus près vous voyez
qu'à gauche la danseuse apparaît
légèrement du dessus à droite en
revanche on la voit légèrement du
dessous et bien notre cerveau n'étant
pas habitué à voir les choses du dessous
aura tendance chez certains à forcer la
vue du dessus c'est cette correction qui
provoquerait le changement de perception
de la rotation cette danseuse m'a un peu
donnée le tournis on passe à l'illusion
suivante baptisée le mur de café à
première vue ce mur composé de carreaux
noir et blanc est un peu biscornu
et c'est vrai que le carreleur aurait pu
utiliser une équerre et un niveau
et pourtant croyez-le ou non
chaque bande qui le compose est
parfaitement rectiligne c'est ça ouais
mon oeil c'est illusion a été étudiée
par l'équipe du chercheur Richard
Gregory en 1979 lorsque l'un d'entre eux
découvre ce carrelage dans un café à
Bristol en Angleterre c'est lui qui a
donné son nom à cette illusion le mur de
café alors pourquoi avons-nous
l'impression que ces bandes ne sont pas
droites alors que tout est parfaitement
aligné et bien ici ce sont les
différences de contrastes qui Berne
notre cerveau en effet lorsque l'air
visuel situé dans le cerveau reçoit des
informations en provenance de nos yeux
elle commence par analyser les
contrastes et les contours pas les
couleurs or dans cette image les
contours sont marqués par de très fines
lignes grises
ce sont elles qui perturbent notre
cerveau s'il distingue facilement la
différence entre le blanc et le gris il
a plus de mal à faire la différence
entre le noir et le gris résultat nous
n'arrivons pas à savoir où s'arrête le
contour des carreaux ainsi
l'enchaînement des carreaux noirs et
blanc ne semblent plus alignés ce qui
donne l'impression que les bandes ne
sont pas rectilignes renversant vous en
voulez encore allez en voici une petite
dernière
l'échiquier d'adelson du nom de son
inventeur un neuroscientifique américain
regardez attentivement les cases A et B
la case a semble plus foncée que la case
B
et pourtant je vous l'assure elles sont
du même gris mais alors pourquoi les
voit-on si différentes et bien
l'explication est simple notre cerveau
se dit que l'ombre du cylindre revers a
légèrement à son brillent pour lui cette
case est blanche il va donc l'éclaircir
mais en réalité c'est ombre est factice
les carrés qui entourent la case B sont
foncées ce contraste renforce
l’impression de notre cerveau il est
persuadé que la case B est plus claire
qu'elle ne l'est et comme ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'il voit un échiquier
l'alternance de casse claire et foncée
lui semble logique si vous n'êtes
toujours pas convaincu et bien je vous
montre cette image
mais en reliant cette fois les cases A
et B maintenant c'est évident elles sont
bien de la même couleur en fait pour
interpréter le monde notre cerveau
s'appuie toujours sur ce conclusion vous
venez de le voir notre perception du
monde est toujours moduler par notre
cerveau notre éducation ou encore notre
culture mais comme moi je suis sûr que
vous avez pris un malin plaisir à vous
laisser berner par les apparences alors
si vous souhaitez voir d'autres
illusions d'optique n'hésitez pas à
faire des propositions en commentaire et
puis si vous avez aimé cette vidéo et
bien likez et abonnez-vous à très
bientôt les épisodes et les épicurieux
[Musique]